Narrator: The kids from
"Stranger Things" may be going
through some changes.
Eleven and the gang are now teenagers,
but Hawkins seems to be stuck in the midst
of a never-ending monster infestation.
Netflix released the
first full-length trailer
for the third season of "Stranger Things."
Here's everything you might've missed.
The third season will take place in 1985,
six months after the events in season 2.
We know this because Dustin is back
from some kind of science camp...
Dustin: At least someone's happy I'm home.
Narrator: called Camp Know Where,
and he's wearing a hat that says '85
on the computer screen.
The song that plays in the beginning
is also from 1985,
Mötley Crüe's "Home Sweet Home."
♪ Long and winding road ♪
In addition to the original cast,
we have some fresh faces
that we get a glimpse
of for the first time.
Cary Elwes from "The Princess
Bride" plays Hawkins' mayor,
whom the residents don't seem
to be happy with
and whose campaign sign
is strikingly similar
to Donald Trump's.
Maya Hawke, daughter of Uma Thurman
and Ethan Hawke,
plays a character named Robin.
Maya will also appear
in Quentin Tarantino's
"Once Upon a Time in Hollywood."
And Jake Busey, Gary Busey's son,
will play someone named Bruce.
Dustin comes home to see
his Tommy Atomic robot
emerge from the shadows.
It's followed by R2-D2,
two tanks, a train,
and Ultra Magnus, who's a Transformer.
The toys move completely on their own,
but it turns out to
just be a surprise party
with Eleven using her powers.
Dustin attacks Lucas using
the Farrah Fawcett hairspray
that Steve gave him in season 2.
Lucas has a little sister named Erica
who's shown in multiple shots,
so she may play a bigger role
in season 3.
The kids are all clearly going
through some growing pains.
A remix of The Who's "Baba O'Riley"
is playing through much of the trailer,
likely to support the characters
becoming part of this "teenage wasteland."
♪ It's only teenage wasteland ♪
Everyone seems to have a new summer job.
Nancy and Jonathan appear to be applying
to or working for the local newspaper,
or they're just trying to alert the press
of something going on in Hawkins.
Billy is a lifeguard at the Hawkins pool.
One of the episodes is titled "The Case
of the Missing Lifeguard."
This could be a reference
to the lifeguard that
passes Billy at the pool
who's later seen in peril.
Steve is working alongside Robin
at an ice cream shop called Scoops Ahoy.
Much of the season looks like
it will take place at
the local Starcourt Mall,
which we saw in an earlier
teaser for the show,
and the finale is actually
called "The Battle of
Starcourt," so something big is expected
to happen here.
Part of the season will probably
revolve around a carnival
called the Fun Fair.
We get a shot of a man with a gun
walking through a hall of mirrors,
showing that things will turn sinister.
At one point,
you can see Hopper standing
in front of a Gravitron,
a classic 1980s carnival ride.
Eleven is back in the Upside Down.
She's also wearing a blue
hair tie on her wrist.
This used to belong to
Sheriff Hopper's daughter
before she died,
which we learned in season 2.
So he must have passed it
on to her at some point.
There's also a very brief glimpse
of Eleven standing blindfolded
in front of a grocery store freezer
full of Eggo waffles.
In every season,
there's at least one shot of Eleven
going straight for the waffles.
In one shot,
Eleven is wearing a yellow shirt
by the blue sea.
A previous teaser included
the mysterious phrase
"When blue and yellow meet in the west."
This could be the moment referenced,
but it could be when the
blue and yellow hands
on the clock meet at the Starcourt Mall
as shown in another teaser.
We also get a first glimpse
of this season's monster.
So far each season of the show has tried
to top itself in terms of its monsters.
In one brief shot,
we see the creature transform right
in front of Jonathan.
It starts off as a slimy ball.
A few shots later,
we see the creature in full.
It's much different from the Demogorgon
from season 1 and the
Demodogs from season 2.
This one has a very spiderlike appearance.
All the other monsters
from the show have drawn
inspiration from Dungeons & Dragons.
Mike: The Demogorgon!
Narrator: It's unclear which monster
this is inspired by,
but there are several possibilities.
In one shot,
we see a bunch of rats scurrying
into a warehouse.
Rats are typically associated
with disease and the plague.
Is there some sort of infection spreading
around town?
It looks like Billy may have caught
whatever it is here.
We won't know anything for sure
until season 3 comes out
on July Fourth.
Did you notice anything we didn't?
Let us know in the comments.